the prime minister out in plain sight
for the first time in days so you see it
looks like something from outer space
but really it's the optic nerve but the
optics around him are terrible and the
nerves visible from a man now under
serious pressure then you send the
results of the scan on a tour of a
hospital today the result he's waiting
for is the outcome of sue grey's
investigation into lockdown parties at
downing street the revelations keep
coming and the latest from his former
top advisor turned foe dominic cummings
accusing the pm of lying about what he
knew is significant he is on the record
saying under oath you are lying that you
were warned about this event and you
went ahead any way that you knew
i can tell you categorically
categorically that nobody told me and
nobody's nobody said that uh this was
something that was against the rules it
was a breach of the of the kobit rules
that we were doing something that wasn't
a
a work event because
uh
frankly i don't think
uh i can't imagine why on earth it would
have gone ahead or why it would have
been allowed
to go ahead
my memory
of this event as i've said
is going out into the garden for
about 25 minutes what i implicitly
thought was a a work event dominic
commerce was your closest advisor and he
said he verbally warned you about this
is he lying i can't believe
uh that we would have gone ahead with an
event that uh people were saying was
against the rules or against uh you're
not saying he didn't warn you he's only
not saying he doesn't nobody warned me
that it was against the rules i can i'm
absolutely categorical because i would i
would remember that okay
so if sue grey uncovers a different
version of events and emerges you did
mislead parliament will you resign we'll
have to see what what she says and
uh i i think that she should be given
the space to get on and conclude her
inquiry and i would urge everybody who
has
uh knowledge of this and understand you
know memories of this to
to tell her what they know some of your
mps that and members of the public think
that this is your barnard castle moment
that the idea that you walked into the
garden
there's 40 people there the tables are
laid out with food and drink and there's
alcohol
being served
in the middle of a lockdown and you
think that's a work event that is just
ludicrous isn't it you are just taking
the mickey out of the british people
well i i look i i you know how silly
that sounds don't you i think what
people need to do is wait and see what
the the report says but i i repeat my
my deep apologies to people for mistakes
that
may have been made on my watch but you
see that that looks ridiculous
i i i
repeat my apologies for any
and all
misjudgments that were made
for which i take full responsibility
one misjudgment that really hurts the
apology to her majesty the queen over
parties allegedly hailed in downing
street the night before her majesty sat
alone at the funeral of her husband it's
the first time we've seen you since
reports emerged not denied by down
street about two boozy parties held in
the garden in the buildings of number
ten the night before prince philip's
funeral when the country was in national
mourning
was having to apologize to the queen
about those parties
the night before she put her husband of
over 70 years she laid him to rest was
that a moment of shame for you i i
deeply and bitterly regret
uh that that that happened and i can
only uh
and renew my apologies both to
uh to her majesty and
uh
to the country
uh
for for misjudgments that that were made
and and for which i take full
responsibility do you think you can
recover from this you might be able to
survive but can you recover
your polling is terrible the public
think you should go your mps are in
revolt six of them have publicly said
you should resign
beth i i understand people's feelings
and i understand why people feel as as
strongly as they do about this issue i
and i i repeat my
apologies for for what happened and i
i i'm heartily heartily sorry for
misjudgments that were made
in in number 10.
boris johnson is known for his
boosterism his bravado his brashness but
today that politician was gone replaced
by a man who's downcast and defeated
this then a prime minister who's perhaps
facing up to the prospect that his time
in number 10 is coming to an end and
none of this happening on his terms
mr cummings warned the prime minister
about the party
his top team had spent the day trying to
put a brave face on it did the piano
know about the party mr ralph but it's
hard to know whether it's a smile or
grimace from the deputy pm the chief
whip with the
spinning without
but the man who lives next door and
might have ambition to move into number
10 more circumspect listen to what the
chancellor says when asked if the prime
minister should resign if he's found to
have lied to parliament well i'm not
going to get into hypotheticals the
ministerial code is is clear on these
matters but as you know sue gray is
conducting an inquiry into the situation
i think it's right that we allow her to
conclude that job
thanks very much
you can't blame him for wanting to lie
down but right now he's in the most
acute fight of his political life and
wondering whether he can hang on
bathrigby sky news